[ Heart beating ]
-Cut!
Everyone, just take five.
-I'm sorry about that last take.
-What the [bleep] is going on?
-I'm just a little out of it.
-Are you on drugs?
Don't [bleep] lie to me.
This has been going on
for a while now.
This has got to stop.
I don't know who
you're hanging out with,
but on my set,
nobody does drugs, all right?
That includes my actors.
Come back in a half-hour
ready to work.
Just --
You're 18 now, man.
Don't [bleep] it up.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Chris Kattan.
That was a clip from "Famous."
Tell us a bit about it.
-It's a --
Well, it's a really good movie,
and, you know,
I'm happy to be in it,
and I chose to be in it, not
just because I got to do drama,
which I like doing,
but Michael Leoni,
who's the director,
had a great vision.
It was based on a play
that he directed,
and this play --
Well, the movie has
the same actors in the play.
So, when I got on board,
his vision was so strong
and powerful that I was like,
"Oh, my God.
I love being part of this,"
you know?
And I took a chance, and I'm
really happy I was in it.
-It's great
to see you doing drama.
It's also very exciting
that you're doing sketch again.
You have a YouTube sketch show
where you're doing
a new sketch every week.
-Yes.
It's called "Hey, Kattan."
-How did you come up with
the name "Hey, Kattan"?
-Whoo!
-Thank you.
-So, somebody on the street
said, "Hey, Kattan!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, most people acknowledge me
by saying, "Hey, Kattan."
They don't go, "Hey, Chris,"
or, "Hey, Chris Kattan."
-You've always been a Kattan.
-Or, "Hey, Chris Kattan.
I heard that Seth Meyers
and his wife
met at your wedding, period."
[ Laughter ]
-Period, end of story.
-End of story.
But, no, yeah.
So, it's a great opportunity
for me to write, you know?
And I get
to direct these shorts.
-Do impressions again?
-Do impressions.
My classic Harrison Ford.
-Harrison Ford.
-Who could forget
my Harrison Ford?
-Not a lot of people can do
a good Harrison Ford.
-No.
[ Laughs ]
Here's my --
Oh, I actually met him.
Well, a few times.
The first time I met him,
I was so excited to meet him
that I was like, "Oh, my God!
You're Harrison Ford!
I'm so excited!
I feel like Short Round!"
[ Laughter ]
That's what I said.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-'Cause I was that excited.
-Sure, sure.
-Can we say short round?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And he said...
[ Laughter ]
I'll hold on that laugh 'cause
you chose to laugh at that.
So, but he --
I said, "I'm so excited.
I feel like Short Round."
He went, "Settle."
[ Laughter ]
And then, I saw him again
at a dentist office,
and I said,
"Hey, Harrison Ford --"
I don't know why I'm screaming,
but I did scream at the time.
That's how I get excited.
-Yeah.
"Hey, Harrison Ford!
It's me!
Remember me, Chris Kattan?"
He went, "Settle," again.
[ Laughter ]
So every time I see him,
he goes, "Settle."
-Yeah.
-The third time,
he said, "Settle."
-Well, I mean, the third time,
you're lucky
he didn't call the cops.
-Yeah, that's right!
-Yeah.
-"Settle."
[ Laughter ]
That would've been -- yeah.
But I hear you do an impre--
We did --
Oh, this is another thing
you can take account
that I helped you with, maybe.
I don't know.
-Yeah.
-But was on "SNL,"
you did a Hugh Grant impression.
-In one of my first "SNLs,"
you put me in a Mango
with Gwyneth Paltrow,
and there I am
doing Hugh Grant right there.
-There you go.
-So, I don't know if you know,
but, like, on "SNL,"
When you first get on the show,
you're like, "Oh, I'd like
to get in the --"
You know, get some air time,
as they say, or whatever.
And you're obviously talented,
and you did an amazing --
-Kind of threw that off...
-Yeah, exactly, I said,
"Oh, my God!
What an amazing
Hugh Grant impression!"
And so there you are
doing Hugh Grant.
And you went...
[ Gibberish ]
-Yeah, yeah.
That was basically it.
That's all I had.
-Yeah.
-That and I, like,
looked like him.
-Well, it's better
than my, "Settle."
-No, the "settle's" good.
-Oh, it is good?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I started going to
impression camp, and I'm very
good at impressions now.
-Impression camp?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I went to a camp.
I went to an intensive camp.
-For impressions.
-For impressions, yeah.
-I don't know if I like that.
-Oh, no.
You don't like it
when you're there.
It's very intense.
-You walk in,
and everybody's doing
different impressions?
-Yeah!
-"Hey, oh..."
I don't want to name out
what you just did,
but I'm a little confused
it's a camp.
-Yeah, but I went,
and it went great.
And I never --
You always had a great Pacino,
and now I have
a passable Al Pacino.
-Oh. Can I see --
Well, my Pacino --
-You do yours first.
[ Laughter ]
-Is this how you are at camp?
-Well, no.
At the end --
-"You do yours first."
[ Laughter ]
So aggressive.
So, I was like --
I still want to go to that camp.
-Yeah, you could be a counselor.
-Why?
I already went from being a guy
who does impressions
to a counselor?
That's so nice.
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
Like, I graduated already.
-Well, but you could lose it
on this Pacino.
-Okay. Well, hold on.
So, my Pacino is basically
the blind Pacino.
You know,
from "Scent of a Woman."
There's different stages
of Pacinos.
There's the "Godfather,"
like, "I know!"
That one from "The Godfather."
But then there's the "Hoo ha!"
That one.
That's the one I did.
So everyone loves that one.
But there's a new Pacino --
-Well, my Pacino started
because he was at some award.
And maybe -- I don't know
which award show it was.
He was in a Zoom room.
-Oh.
-And so we took great joy in
thinking about Al Pacino going
like, "Al Pacino
in the Zoom room!"
[ Laughter ]
"Look at me."
-That's what he did?
-"I'm in a Zoom room."
-"I'm in a Zumba room."
-"I don't know what this is."
[ Laughter ]
They said,
"Meet me in the Zoom room."
You'd get cancelled.
You can't do that impression.
-You can't do it anymore?
-Yeah, you can't do Pacino.
But he does a --
[ Laughs ]
I know he's got "House of Gucci"
movie coming out.
So, he's Italian, he's like,
"I am -- you la puciata feta!"
-Oh, is that --
-"La ta tuci, la pucci!"
-Have you seen "House of Gucci"?
-No, I have not.
-Oh, wow.
So, you're so confident
in your Al Pacino impression...
[ Laughter ]
-I went to the West Coast
Camp of Impressions.
-Oh, you did?
And they said,
"'House of Gucci,'
just take your Pacino,
put a little Italian in it,
do it again."
Now that I know
what I'm listening for,
do an Al Pacino
in the "House of Gucci"
that you haven't seen yet.
-"Oh! Uh, what-a everybody's
wearing a-here?"
[ Laughter ]
-It's very good.
-Thank you.
-You guys, that's Chris Kattan.
"Famous" is in theaters
and available on demand
December 10th.